ben justement et maintenant nous allons
avoir le plaisir de vous retrouver le
mois prochain dans un film de joël séria
dans le deuxième film que je tourne avec
joël séria carisa effet avec lui j'avais
ces deux dash charlie et ses deux
nénettes qui était un film à la fois
touchants pittoresque plein de plein de
vie vous faisiez un personnage de
marchands forains
à part çà et là je veux joueur
présentant au parapluie a représenté en
parade c'est un film qui est
certainement les mêmes qualités que vous
évoquez là mais qui en plus est un film
beaucoup plus lyrique beaucoup plus
baroque que l'autre enfin il ya toujours
toutes les qualités de seria dans le
film et c'est sûrement une comédie
beaucoup plus aboutie qu l'autre et on
va voir le film au mois d'août et il
s'appelle les galettes de pont-aven
voilà j'avais jane pitt pour la bretagne
en effet pour le porter mais excusez moi
alors plus vers 3 oui oui c'est mon
premier jeu je passe toutes mes vacances
dans ce coin je suis c'est un pays que
j'aime beaucoup et je suis très heureux
de penser qu'on va le voir parce que
c'est un pays bouleversant j'espère que
je vais essayer de se promener dans dans
les chemins creux
j'aurais pu large de la bretagne est
admirablement évoqué dans le film c'est
très très c'est très beau et une grande
partie du film se tourne le nom sur la
lande au bord de la mer dans conte avait
même dans tous les types et autres
pontes a même élevé j'appelle les
galettes de pont-aven parce que on y
fabrique des galettes on y mange des
galets non mais ça n'a rien à voir ça
s'appelle des galettes de pont-aven
parce que le personnage qui s'adonne à
la peinture tout en étant un joueur le
blu merce après de nombreuses péripéties
finisse son séjour à punta rennes en
vendant sur la plage des galettes de
pomme d'api et des crêpes et voilà
pourquoi le film s'appelle les galettes
de pont-aven et puis en même temps je
pense que si les peintres il y retrouve
le les grands souvenirs la grande ombre
de gauguin tous les autres pains de
l'école de pompeyrie gariel vraiment
d'en face à na rien a voir le film si
vous voulez n'est pas du tout un film
sur la peinture
intune ce n'est absolument pas pour
évoquer toutes là la grande période de
google deux autres plaintes de pont-aven
se trouve comme ça tout simplement le
voyageur de commerce que je joue par
hasard débarque à pont-aven cette
médaille heures charlie et ses deux
nénettes s'il avait fallu le caractérise
et qu'est ce qu'on aurait dit à un
moment de la vie quoi un moment vu cela
à un moment de la vie avec des gens qui
vivent et qu on a plaisir à regarder là
je pense que c'est la même chose qui
vous entourent travail de nombreux
comédiens magnifiques qui l'a frais sont
ils à pied plus il ya andréa ferréol il
y à jacques goupil que nous avons déjà
vu dans l'idée des neiges de charlie
sheen vlv noël charlie en effet il y as
je voudrais pas en oublier les encore
plein d'acteurs épatants ce mois qui
rend ma bouteille à romain bouteille
également qui joue le curé de dutil pays
où se tourner le film
voilà et bien je peux vous dire jean
pierre marielle que j'ai hâte de le voir
mais que nous sommes je crois de
nombreux avoir envie de le voir
et quels sont vos autres projets il ya
d'autres filment en train et va sortir
du out je vais tourner calmos le nouveau
film de bertrand blier
je vais retrouver mon lit acolyte jean
choix nous allons jouer deux hommes
poursuivis par les femmes toute approche
heureuse des styles et bien jean pierre
marielle j'attends tout ça avec plaisir
je dois dire que vraisemblablement je
mangerai des galettes de pont-aven avant
de voir le bafa car dans quelques jours
je vais les retrouver ce beau pays d'oz
et blabla chante et dès que je serai de
retour au mois d'août je me précipiterai
pour voir le film merci